So Athena's been building a lot of models in her architecture class so that she
can depict buildings. And she figured out one really easy way to build a
rectangular building. All you do is you take a rectangular sheet of paper, and
you just cut a square out of each corner. So you cut a square out of all four
corners, and make each square the same size. So let's try it out and see what
happens.
[SOUND]
Voila, four squares drawn Okay, great, so now we have a rectangle without any
corners. Now all I have to do is fold up the different flaps. And look, we have
a box. If you want to make it a permenent box, we can always tape each corner
together. And look at that, we have a building. Now, this may look pretty
simple right now, but If you think about it, we've only dealt with area in this
class so far, and that's really all that Athena's talked about in her
architecture classes so far too. But being able to make a box or a building, or
whatever you want to call this, is really powerful. This is a three dimensional
object. Means it has space that it occupies, and I can do stuff with it
like[NOISE] Fill it with M&amp;Ms.
[SOUND]
So this could be a model building or it can hold stuff. It can hold M&amp;Ms, it
can hold my tape,[SOUND] I can do whatever I want with it because this shape
takes up volume. It doesn't just have area, it has a volume. So this is a
totally new concept for art class and also a new concept for Athena. It's
going to be super important as she continues to study architecture.